is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 percent discount on
a wide range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
go to kuala lude app in charlotte the
app tracks versus pages and time spent
reading and the verses to pages function
takes you from reading a few verses a
day to a few pages a day this project is
for the real enthusiasts if there's
enough of us out there this will become
the future of quran apps and support the
project if you can't inshallah may allah
bless
how are you guys doing today i'm going
to be reacting to a man referred to as
kevin samuels a man who's seen as one of
the most influential voices you could
even say the most influential voice in
what is referred to as the red pill
movement
now what is the red pill movement that
is another discussion for another day
but suffice it for me to say today that
this individual he has women come onto
his platforms like usually divorcees
single mothers women that have been
married before when they have had
relationships have have our children and
so on maybe over 30
and he proceeds to dismantling you could
say shutting down what is referred to at
least in the literature as
positive illusions that they may have of
the so-called
yes the so-called marriage market
he will deconstruct that he'll make them
see reason look to reason be more
realistic their expectations of marriage
and so on and he actually became
prominent on the internet after one
particular video what would you rank
yourself on a scale from one to ten you
cannot use seven
would i rate myself
just your face
uh my face when i wake up five but when
i put myself together six
okay
and how tall are you
five five dress size
i'm sorry your dress size
okay so that makes you
if you give yourself a five that's
average
yes
so average looking women
tend not to get
high earning men
they tend to get average men
so um did you did you i mean stop right
there stop right there
stop right there breathe and digest
you're 35 years old and you can look
around and see the world
you don't tend to see
higher earning men
with average looking women
off rip
if you do see them they got them they
got their average looking woman when
they were both really young and he built
his way up but a man earning the kind of
money you're talking about does not go
for an average looking woman
i mean my body is not average so but
ma'am you please don't make me say it
hey what
i really just wanted some advice i love
you i'm giving you i'm giving you advice
but you're not taking it
the advice is man ma'am
you're average looking at best
i'm taking it in but okay but you're not
accepting the fact that
okay
right so we've just seen what kind of
flavor that his content has to offer now
of course for better or for worse
this can be very uncomfortable watching
to be honest with you putting women in a
spot like that speaking to them publicly
like that you know sometimes quite
condescendingly like that
but on the other hand you could argue
that as ignoble as it may seem on the
face on prima facie value that in fact
that this serves some kind of noble
functionality and yes i do agree that
there are many delusions of grandeur
that men and or women more do have
uh when it comes to the so-called
marriage market and sometimes this can
be very detrimental many more and more
people are dying alone as he puts it
it's true yes some more and more people
are dying alone because they cannot come
to terms with the fact that their
circumstances have changed that means
that their options the pool of
candidates that they can marry has also
been limited this is the truth this is
the reality this is the demographic
truth however having said this i must
say i must put forward now as a point of
criticism constructive
criticism to mr samuels that in fact i
believe from watching his content and
seeing what he has to say although
there's great benefit of course there is
yes there is that there is also
injustice and that is a strong word to
use but it's unfair it's unfair the way
he puts the onus on black women and does
not put such an onus or even a
comparable level
of responsibility on black men or other
kinds of men
now
to be honest with you i
kind of looked at this first when i saw
a community community post that he had
put up recently on his channel whereby
he kind of looks at the demographic data
i think this is something that was
produced by the times
and
he shows that well black women are most
likely to be single and this goes in
line with his grand narrative his meta
narrative or his hypo hypothesis or
thesis
grand thesis that it's because of black
women's behavior potentially or their
attitudes that this is the case i must
say sociologically this is an extremely
weak
extremely weak pathetic i have to say
sorry to say it's kevin yeah listen to
me this is a pathetic sociological
approach
and this is a criticism of the red pill
movement and criticism of you because
quite frankly yes you attack feminism
and yes i attack feminism we attack
feminism why is this problematic the
reason why this is problematic kevin
listen to me is because there are myriad
reasons
why black women might be more
disadvantaged in the first instance in
terms of selecting black men we know
because of the system and otherwise the
system the way the system is the way
this uh but because of all these reasons
black men are more likely to be
incarcerated they are more likely to be
dead they are more likely to be
unemployed
for socio-economic reasons for
historical reasons yes yes yes i am not
denying that
but the fact that these myriad reasons
exist in the first place means that the
pool of
uh selected or pro you know preferred
partners for black women who for the
most part as the literature shows that
i'm sure you're aware of it prefer black
men would become narrowed
therefore you cannot it's unjust for you
to say that the reason why is because of
their attitude even further i'm not
saying you said this by the way but that
is the inference quite frankly
definitely based on the reading of the
main body of work that you have
that's the first thing the second thing
is i came across something quite
disturbing i have to say kevin this was
disturbing and it made me look at you in
a different way it made me look at you
in a different light and i was very very
disappointed it was a clip in particular
where you refer to black women in
general
as less aesthetically attractive than
other types of women let's take a look
at this
clip and look at what they and that's
the thing
you can they're in the same you know
beauty is subjective that's that's
another fallacy beauty is not subjective
that's what's going on that's why we
have the that's why we have the golden
ratio the fibonacci equations you can
look at facial symmetry and see that
that's right beautiful people you can
map you can map their facial structure
and if it goes to a mathematical
calculation oh yeah beauty is universal
and the thing is
we're talking about black women they are
on the opposite end of the spectrum on
all ranks facial symmetry even to the
way to black women are starting to look
more masculine
and this one you start putting on
additional makeup and you know
weave and all those other kind of stuff
to where guys are just saying damn and
you're not even going to the gym no
trying to keep yourself in shape and you
don't have a good attitude i would
rather not i have to say kevin this is
absolutely diabolical
i am absolutely astounded that you a man
that i thought was quite an intellectual
man who is meant to be the leading
voice for the red pill movement that you
could make such a ridiculous pathetic
argument it's absolutely
disgusting i have to say
why it's a colonial mindset you have
kevin
why would you generalize black women in
such a way
to think that they uh
on the other side of the spectrum how
dare you actually quite frankly how dare
you speak of black women like that and i
will say how dare you say that how dare
you say that i don't care if you're
black and i'm an arab and i'm middle
eastern but i will say how dare you
because quite frankly the reasoning you
gave would be pathetic reasoning on the
standard of even what we call gcse
students which our students are 15 16
years old kevin samuels
golden mean
golden mean is that what you're really
saying to me right now kevin samuels
golden mean you know in the 19th century
almost all of these studies that were
done relating to the golden meanest
link to aesthetic beauty have been
inclusive
go and look this up yourself now i don't
even know how you are doing this let's
let's let's step back a second are you
what is the postulation that the women
that are more symmetrical
will stimulate
what system of a man are you talking
about the testosterone system are you
talking about the oxytocin system are
you talking about the dopamine system
what system in particular
are less likely to have induce what
romantic love sexual arousal for men
what is your argument exactly you're
saying it's an objective fact do you
even know what objective fact is
this is pathetic this is academic
failure my friend and if this is the
level that you're bringing to the table
then you are low value in terms of
intellectual ability low value man you
are that you're a low value man you are
you call yourself a nine out of ten
you're not a nine out of ten in
intellectual ability if you're gonna
throw black women under the bus just
like this you're not
now i have to say something else
having said this
i will say to you
that the whole
mantra
or the whole
premise of the red pill idea what the
man has to see himself as the prize
diminishing i have to say a trivializing
i have to say of the reciprocal element
of the relationship
a denial i have to say or even a
minimizing i must say
of male responsibility male black
responsibility is something which will
create
unstable families listen to me it will
destabilize
it will destabilize the black community
more than these the cia and the fbi and
the who
want to destabilize it already you're
destabilizing your own community from
within telling men
increase their body counts really this
is the message is this the message
increase the body counts and all these
kinds of things and we have muslim men
in our community following this kind of
nonsense thinking that this is kind of a
refreshing
other opinion to the feminist movement a
reaction is to the feminist movement
this is not something we as the muslims
will ever subscribe to and should never
describe subscribe to because quite
frankly it's a pickup artist culture my
friend yeah you have i i call you now
kevin samuels to a better system yes i
make this invitation to i give this
invitation to you directly instead of
putting your hopes in raising your money
and income and telling other people to
do i'm not saying don't make money make
your money but don't value yourself
highly based on economic indicators as
you have indicated in other videos that
this is mainly the thing to do make ten
thousand pounds a month or do this ten
thousand dollars i should say this is
not the way to create high value
people in the black community or in the
american community or in the world the
way to create high value
yes high value men is that men that know
their purpose and let me tell you
something it's not just men that should
know their purpose it's women that
should know their purpose as well you
know what the purpose is is to worship
the creator not the creation
you're a christian i know samuel you
worship a middle eastern man
quite frankly
you might be thinking what's this arab
doing telling me what to do and i'm not
saying that you are thinking that maybe
you're not thinking that maybe some of
your followers are saying what this
middle eastern was here arab telling me
what to do a lot of the people in the
black community worship a middle eastern
man which is jesus christ we're saying
keep away from this worship of men and
statues and actually worship the creator
and in terms of the problems the
institutionalized problems that you'll
find then the black community loudness
specifically deal with the so-called
marriage market then i have to say
pollution is actually something which
seemingly on the face of it will solve
your demographic dilemma
how do you absorb such women
who are otherwise
uh will die alone in your words how do
you absorb them into the marriage
markets
and allow them to marry high value in
your understanding material is
capitalistic understanding your uh
supply side economics type understanding
of what high value how do you absorb
them the best way to absorb them is to
pair them with a man who's already
paired through an institution which is
ancient and has bulletproof testing
which ensures rights of men and women
which is the politicians institution in
the islamic system now i say these are
solutions you you have a purpose and
you're not going to get men and or women
to do what you want them to do unless
you have a greater purpose then do you
want to die alone do you want to die
alone
some women i tell you will want to die
who is that the best you can do kevin
samuels we say no it's not about whether
you want to die alone that should not be
the ultimate incentive the ultimate
incentive kevin samuels is the purpose
of life and the purpose of life is to
worship one god not the middle eastern
man not the chinese man not the black
man not the white man to worship one god
and then to have a family a stable
family
that complies by that reality
yes that metaphysic yes that religious
metaphysic and that will incentivize and
that has not just that will we have a
track record my friend thousand four
hundred years in fact even further than
that going back to the other
dispensations the previous dispensations
that this will incentivize the spiritual
incentivization is more
uh is more motivating than almost
anything you can provide you have a
spiritual motive a motivation
a religion with pure clean
structured guidelines sorry to say which
does not exist in the christian faith
and i'm going to say that
straightforwardly you don't have that
okay and then
you have families
which are stable and women that can be
absorbed into other
families
which will solve the demographic issue
but it all starts with purpose and kevin
samuels i have to say the parlance
uh and then the lexus of some of what
you say
in terms of
telling men just kind of giving them the
advice that you give them i don't think
will solve the issues in your country
and in your community listen to me kevin
samuels
tell the people
not it's not about the body count my
friend
it's not about the body count tell the
people to find their purpose in life
yeah and you and you for a man
who claims
or at least the movement itself itself
claims that the man should be deprived
and he shouldn't be thinking about it to
be honest you're focusing too much in my
opinion on getting women's attention
let's think about uh bigger things
because we're older men right now me and
you especially you salaam alaikum allah